[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome back to the best business show
why is this a best business show simply
because we said so and that is how the
internet works
i am here with my brothers joe and john
how do you know their names are joe and
john real simple their names are on the
back of their chairs we are in business
today we have a big big show for you the
best business show is the show that we
wish that we had when we were learning
about business investing in finance
first topic right out of the gate yes
you see it today is friday everyone
knows summer friday has been going on
for a while that means we're out of here
early we got things to go do but some of
you right now are sitting there you
might have to wear a sweatshirt some
pants walk outside it's 50 degrees well
it's always summer here in miami and so
we've got brand new merch the best
business show miami merch that's right
it is always summer in miami this [ __ ]
is fly that's all i gotta say this [ __ ]
is fly
i will be rocking this all the time in
the store we have this on t-shirts long
sleeves hoodies the whole nine yards but
if you go to the bestbusiness show.com
miami you can buy you can buy it there i
also though someone on our team chris
sent us last night completely
unsolicited he said yo i got a little
promo video so watch this this is what
we put together for this merch right
here
[Music]
hey
[Music]
tell me that wasn't fl fire that was
fine that was pretty fun you see you two
over there sitting in the boat racing
jet boat well you guys were a step
behind joey yachts
you got it it was the jet boat
he's good at good energy you saw me i
was a little ahead of you guys because
we were racing and i was winning no
problem i think we were in the same boat
i don't think so okay not only do we
have awesome awesome new merch but of
course it's friday you know what it is
last week i almost forgot this week i'm
not going to forget if we have a friday
show guess what that means what joe's
best friend mufasa gotta get a little
warm up with mufasa before we get
started we don't have mufasa it doesn't
set the right tone for the show on
friday
[Music]
there he is
[Music]
[Music]
there's just something about this video
i'm walking it out get a little high
energy ready to rock and roll on a
friday if you don't like mufasa you
shouldn't watch this show that's
basically the uh the energy we need on a
daily basis just look at him walking it
out ready to rock and roll
john listens to this song before he goes
out on friday and saturday nights
fridays what i listen to when you wake
up yeah but get a little energy in there
oh and you bounce like that to the
bathroom
[Laughter]
you never know you never know
oh what a great video all right so we
got a ton of stuff to get through today
then we've got the young wizard will
clemente he'll be coming on uh to talk
us through all of the on-chain metrics
for this week as many of you know when
you woke up today you got the little uh
sleep crust out of your eyes washed your
face looked at your phone oh [ __ ]
bitcoin's up like 10
we've got our first chart of the day
where we've got bitcoin the s p gold
silver euro yen rendon b and oil all
lined up next to each other bitcoin just
dominating the market the apex predator
of the financial markets is ready to
roll when you wake up the beast it moves
and as we know we are in october also
known as shocktober q4 of this year
we've been saying it now for months
literally to the point where you are
probably tired of hearing it q4 of this
year is going to be insane and there's
no better way to start off october 1
shocktober with a 10
move in the bitcoin price on top of that
if we go and we look at bitcoin gold and
the smp and compare it over one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
year time frame what do you see bitcoin
the apex predator of financial markets
absolutely dominating anything else you
could have bought almost up 1 million
percent over the last decade i didn't
make it up it's a video game number i
know but that is how much bitcoin has
appreciated on top of that bitcoin is up
340
over the last year all the boomers out
there all the mainstream media all the
haters the critics every single person
wants you to believe that bitcoin is
dead that bitcoin is worthless that
nothing is going on it's up 340
in the last year that is more than 10x
what the s p 500 is up so do not listen
to what they are saying just keep
looking at the data over a two-year
period it's up almost 500 percent over a
five-year period it is up seven thousand
six hundred percent you literally could
have bought the s p 500 10 years ago and
you would have a lower return than if
you just bought bitcoin two years ago
that's what ends up happening on top of
that gold absolute trash down eight
percent for the year
gold no longer works if you're looking
for an inflation hedge asset gold is
dead cpi the uh cpi index is showing
over 5
inflation on a real return basis gold is
down 13.
double digit negative growth for gold in
the last 12 months absolutely pathetic
if you hold gold you should drop it and
probably look at digital sound money
that's how this works now before we get
into all the fun stuff of what's going
on in the current news we got to get our
likes up we're only at 230 likes that's
not how this works we are going to give
away something special today
never before big giveaway today big big
big boy giveaway right before the show i
was thinking what could i do to say
thank you to everyone for watching all
week for hitting the like button for
subscribing for watching every video etc
so i texted a friend who happens to run
ate sleep and i said hey
what if i give away
one of the eight sleep pods so that
somebody else can put their little head
down to sleep at night and sleep well on
innate sleep
i sleep on one joe sleeps on one john do
you got one
no not yet oh damn so y'all better have
these you cannot win john can not win
the giveaway john's getting one uh we
sleep on it every night i literally turn
it about as cold as i can make it
without freezing and i just fall asleep
and i sleep deep every night john tells
me oh what'd you do sleep on an age
sleep we get it
that's how good it is i absolutely love
the thing we're gonna give away one for
free today the only way we're giving it
away though what's what's the goal for
the likes we got a short show we're only
going to go to about 12 15 12 20 today
what do we think we can get to 1500
1500 likes we'll give away the eight
sleep mattress there's one eight sleep
mattress can ship it anywhere in the
world we'll give it to one person in the
audience completely free from the boys
on a summer with your energy today you
know you slept on innate sleep
two nights ago i slept 10 hours what up
oh last night i slept eight hours like
hey you know if you sleep you'll win
everybody this gift has a uh what is the
value it's over a thousand dollars for
sure easy yeah 1800 2000. i mean i think
it's priceless but you know
i agree it's great
i love it i don't know why you're using
all them
i just think it's a priceless ass
mattress
[Laughter]
so we're gonna give away one of them
today uh but we gotta get to 1.5 k likes
which means you at home free content
free coverage of whatever's going on in
the world from us you just gotta press
the like button that's your entry fee to
get in all right yesterday we had a
politician who very expertly cornered uh
jerome powell and said hey do you have
intentions to actually ban bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies in the united states
and jerome powell responded and said
that there are no plans to do that so
we've got the video very quickly that
we're going to play uh that was by the
way great graphic right here literally
perfect graphic just got a little
bitcoin at the podium ready to rock and
roll uh so we've got this video that
we're gonna pull up and we're going to
show you uh what exactly was the talk
track from jerome powell and this
politician uh and then we're gonna talk
about what the impact of uh this um kind
of public statement coming from uh
jerome powell in the federal reserve is
give us one second here we're gonna pull
up the video and you can hear it right
for yourself digital currencies and
their impact on stable coin and other
cryptocurrencies and you stated and i
think i quote uh you correctly here you
wouldn't need stable coins you wouldn't
need cryptocurrencies if you had a
digital u.s currency so mr chairman as a
matter of policy is it your intention to
ban or limit the use of cryptocurrencies
like we're seeing in china
no and and i i immediately realized i
had misspoken there i didn't mean to
take the word cryptocurrency out of that
sentence and i would say
fairly widely understood that central
bank digital currencies could perform
some of the some of the uh could make
but no intention to ban less
no intention about no intention to ban
them but they're you know the stable
coins are are like money market funds
they're like bank deposits but they're
to some extent outside the regulatory
perimeter and it's it's appropriate that
they be regulated same activity same
regulation
all right great video here a couple of
key things out of this first the
chairman of the federal reserve
explicitly saying no intention to ban
bitcoin obviously bitcoin is going wild
on the internet but remember you can't
always take everything they say at face
value they could easily tomorrow come
out and say hey we didn't intend to do
it that then now we intend to do it so
you can't just simply say we're
completely out of the clear but i think
that this again goes to the point where
it would be idiotic for us to become
more abrasive or to outlaw or ban
anything to do with bitcoin why we've
got a tweet here from nick
can't mine which i have no clue who this
is but i liked what they said where it
said jerome powell says the us has no
plans to ban bitcoin fantastic now it's
time to act we must take advantage of
this chance to fully adopt a bitcoin
standard so we can cement our position
as the global leader and dominate and
crush the ccp if an authoritarian
centrally planned economy wants to say
we are not going to participate in a
decentralized open system
then the democratic and capitalistic
economies around the world have an
opportunity again it's like a running
back takes the hand off the sea parts
before them and they're going for the
end zone that is the opportunity in
front of us but we got to get going and
so if they're going to outlaw it if
they're going to ban it if they're going
to not participate
then we as the united states should make
sure that if anyone benefits from this
we benefit more than anybody else and
that's the entire point here and so the
last point around this is not only did
the chairman of the federal reserve say
that the united states does not have
intentions to ban bitcoin on top of that
he explicitly stated that stable coins
were in their crosshairs they believe
that they are more like money market
funds or some sort of debt instrument
and they think that they should be
regulated
just as much as those traditional
financial products so bitcoin being a
decentralized digital currency has very
different characteristics and aspects to
it than stable coins or most of the
other assets in this industry and so i
explicitly called out this morning in a
tweet that i said china banned bitcoin
and it went higher in price within one
week
adoption increases every time a country
becomes more abrasive to decentralized
technologies we've now seen this when
china bans it bitcoin's price went up we
know that in nigeria and pakistan when
they outlawed it and they banned it in
those countries adoption went up more
people came on the network more people
started to mine the peer-to-peer network
saw much much more transaction volume
when countries become abrasive to
decentralized technologies they
essentially run marketing campaigns for
the public to go and learn more about it
and so naturally what happens if we are
going to have countries around the world
that want to sit this one out thank you
we appreciate you giving this
opportunity to the united states the
united states should hurry up should
adopt this embrace it and become the
global leader what do we think yeah i
mean i agree i think uh when you think
about innovation and technological
progress it's all about uh it revolves a
lot around capital flows right and you
have to look at kind of what countries
and what areas are willing to adopt that
uh and and get those capital that
capital come into their country and the
u.s clearly has an opportunity with
china shutting it down and say hey we're
not going to allow you to buy sell
exchange etc
the u.s has opened that door as being
able to be one of the larger countries
that come in and accept that right so uh
i think they have a huge opportunity in
front of them
it helps with powell saying that they're
not gonna ban and do all these other
things sure but i think ultimately we
need to see uh maybe they don't need to
buy it or whatever it is but we need to
see that welcoming and that uh that
ability to to get people to come here
and innovate and do all these certain
things
john what do you think sounds bullish to
me
that's the uh no for the holder sounds
bullish um i wasn't expecting them to
ban it they definitely kind of gone
towards the regulatory scrutiny of it
right with the stable coins um and all
the different companies that have tried
to do the yield on stable coins but i
it doesn't really change my outlook on
bitcoin in general i see it i see it
going up in q4 but
let's let's see what the us does over
the next 12 months and if they if they
kind of pursue that central bank digital
currency i also think it separates like
bitcoin from all the other stuff right
he he clearly was talking more about
stable coins for sure uh but i think
when it comes to banning various
cryptocurrencies and and things like
stable coins and stuff like that there's
a lot there's a lot of other stuff uh i
would call within like the digital asset
market that they i think i believe that
they would worry about before uh bitcoin
and some of the other more stable
currencies the part to me that is uh
fascinating around this uh one you get
the separation of bitcoin and everything
else two is uh there is a big difference
between we are proponents of we are
going to embrace something and we're not
going to be negative to it right and
right now all we have is confirmation
that we're not going to ban it we are
not going to outlaw it that doesn't
necessarily mean that we're going to go
all in on it we're going to embrace it
whatever if the united states wanted to
do that a very simple thing would be
what the senate candidate blake master
suggested earlier this week which is
just we should buy some as a strategic
reserve right just like we would buy
gold or anything else we should put that
in the strategic reserves the second
thing that i think would be very
interesting and probably be one of the
most important decisions that we can
make is that we should change the
treatment of bitcoin to go from being
treated as a property so that when you
spend it you actually get hit with
capital gains tax and instead we should
treat it as a currency so that you can
actually spend bitcoin as a currency
just like the us dollar and not have to
pay any sort of taxes on your gains that
feels like that is one of the biggest
reasons why people end up not using it
as a digital currency right now it's
great because there are more people
holding it and then we end up setting up
for these kind of supply shocks or
shocktober type stuff
but what it doesn't help with is the
ability to actually want to spend
bitcoin as a medium of exchange if we
ever get to that point where they deem
it as a currency or it starts being used
more and more as like kind of that
global reserve currency that a lot of
people want it to be
would capital gains would that ever be
implemented in there right so if it ever
actually got adopted and i guess
officially deemed a currency would some
people be able to avoid taxes that way
if it gets if it ends up being a
currency then basically you if you spend
it right if i go to dinner tonight and i
uh buy it with dollars i pay the price
of the meal and i pay sales tax but
that's it if i go and i buy it with
bitcoin i pay the price of the meal i
pay sales tax and i pay capital gains
from when i bought the bitcoin if they
take it from being treated as property
from a tax perspective and they say no
it's just a currency just like the
dollar or a peso or euro or whatever
then all of a sudden i won't get hit
with that capital gains tax when i
actually spend it so it's one thing when
you're buying an asset and you're hoping
it appreciates in value and then you
sell it and you've got to gain and they
want to tax that realize capital gains
not unrealized but it's a whole
different thing if i'm literally going
on buying goods and services with it
right there's a friction to it and so
it's pretty incredible to see how much
bitcoin has been adopted and used as a
medium of exchange already even though
that tax implication is there yeah but i
also think like do you really think
that's gonna make a drastic difference
when it comes to uh people's willingness
to spend as a currency because at the
end of the day i think a lot of people
still think it's gonna appreciate value
right and you're not gonna want or
people aren't willing to give up uh that
asset that they believe is gonna
appreciate in value for something that
may not appreciate in value right food
obviously if you eat the meal it's not
gonna appreciate or anything like that
tesla we saw no one was buying their
cars with bitcoin and all this other
stuff so yes there are certain things
that need to happen for it to become
more widely accepted as a currency but
ultimately if people continue to believe
that we're nowhere close to kind of a
stability price of where they think
it'll go long term it's less likely that
they're willing to or will uh will go
out and spend the money
23 billion dollars was settled on the
bitcoin blockchain in the last 24 hours
yeah 23 billion which means we would be
on track to do somewhere around five six
trillion dollars of total on-chain
settlement on an annualized basis that
would be about fifty percent of visa and
mastercard's uh transaction volume in a
single year so that is a big big number
now it was down over the last couple of
months on a daily basis because price
was down uh people weren't using it as
much but now we're starting to come
rocking back and so i think what we've
got to remember is there's a difference
between the exchange traded volume the
exchange traded volume uh in the last 24
hours was only around eight eight and a
half billion but the actual on-chain
settlement value was over 20 billion
dollars about 23 billion dollars and so
uh that is people actually using it now
that doesn't include what's going on in
the lightning network as well and so i
think over time we're seeing more and
more people start to use this already as
a store value now more of a medium of
exchange and what we need is we need
better tax treatment so that people in
america who are subject to this uh
capital gains tax would have a
a bigger financial incentive to go ahead
and use it rather than it's more of a
punishment right you can use taxes as a
carrot or as a stick right now this
capital gains tax is being used as a
stick basically saying don't spend
bitcoin don't spend bitcoin every time
you do it you get slapped on the wrist
well what happens if we actually remove
that and we say listen it's a currency
just like anything else it's literally a
digital decentralized currency it is now
legal tender in another country right
and so we should treat it like a
currency we should allow people to spend
it don't tax them on it and figure out
other ways to tax it they buy it for an
investment purpose and then they sell it
into dollars without buying a good or
service you can tax the capital gains
but if they use it to buy goods and
services allow them to do that without
the capital gains tax alex stewie made a
good point in the chat um el salvador
actually is giving a discount for people
that buy gas
in the chiva wall like using bitcoin so
there's also the incentive play there
right where you can almost incentivize
people to let go of their bitcoin but as
we see long-term holders continue to um
continue to just acquire more and more
bitcoin yeah i think it also depends on
on kind of where you're located uh
geographically also right so like if you
think about here in the u.s most people
are buying it not necessarily as a
medium of exchange but more so as an
investment or a store of value right
getting their money out of dollars and
putting it into bitcoin in other places
of the world that may not be the case
right it may be something where their
currency is depreciating at a rapid rate
and they want something that is going to
appreciate in value or uh that they feel
will at least stay kind of neutral
relative to their own currency so i
think it depends on kind of where you're
situated in the world uh but yeah
obviously helping things that are
related to the taxation of actually
spending it as a currency or as a medium
of exchange would help this is why
what's going on on twitter is so
interesting to me so many people are
actually buying bitcoin as a savings
technology they're saying to themselves
hey i am not going to save in dollars i
don't want to buy another asset to
actually protect my wealth i want to buy
and hold my wealth in bitcoin that
allows me to protect my purchasing power
and actually appreciate my purchasing
power over long periods of time if you
believe to joe's point earlier that
bitcoin is going to appreciate in u.s
dollar exchange value and your
purchasing power is going to increase
you are disincentivized from using it
but we have to separate bitcoin the
asset which is what people are buying
and holding from bitcoin the payment
network and what twitter has done via
their partnership with strike where i'm
an investor strike is allowing people to
send dollars across the bitcoin rails
and this is a very very key point is
when i go ahead and i sent this morning
i sent 200 to the human rights
foundation all these people have been
sending me money from around the world i
took 200 and i sent it to the human
rights foundation when i did that what
is occurring is i'm sending dollars
across the bitcoin payment rails i'm not
sending bitcoin i don't have to actually
have bitcoin in a bitcoin wallet to send
it i'm sending dollars now how does that
happen what literally is occurring is
the dollars are being converted into
bitcoin the bitcoin is being sent across
the lightning network and is being
converted back into dollars i send
dollars they receive dollars i don't
even need to know anything about bitcoin
i don't need no bitcoins involved i
don't even have to understand what
payment rails are assets etc all i know
is i sent 200 they received 200
and so what becomes really interesting
about that is that interface is
completely interoperable with all the
other interfaces on the lightning
network if let's say that john was on
paypal and i was on um uh cash app john
wants to venmo me but i don't have venmo
i can't receive anything from john or if
i'm on cash app and i want to send it to
john and john doesn't have cash app he
can't receive it from me because the
underlying technology stacks are
completely different they're centralized
siloed uh closed networks so the venmo
network allows you to communicate or
transact with venmo users cache app lets
you do with cache app now all of a
sudden when these interfaces plug into
an open monetary network which means
that all of the infrastructure is shared
i can now send it to somebody who's on
strike i can send it to somebody who's
on twitter or i can send it to somebody
on a platform that i've never even heard
of before and that is that
interoperability becomes really
interesting because now everyone is
incentivized to join if all of a sudden
i can simply just connect to this open
monetary network and i can drastically
increase the number of users that can
interact with my users i'm expanding my
system it's very similar to like the
restaurant problem if you've ever heard
about an intersection when there's one
restaurant there's a certain number of
people that go there most people think
that when you add a second restaurant to
the intersection now they're going to
compete with each other but what a lot
of studies show is you actually want to
build density so if you have five six
seven eight ten restaurants all on that
corner people start to think of it as oh
i'm hungry where do you wanna eat i
don't know let's just go down there and
we'll find somewhere to eat and so it
drastically increases the foot traffic
for every single restaurant by building
density same exact thing at play here is
by including or joining this open
monetary network everybody is
incentivized to do it because they get
more users they get more volume and they
ultimately end up getting a deeper and
deeper network effect where the users
from their interface are going to use it
more often because they can actually
communicate with or transact with more
and more people on the network as well
yeah but like venmo is incentivized not
to open their network to be able to use
it with those other apps get some more
downloads all revenue everything that
goes along with that well it's their own
product right but i think uh what's
what's interesting is like twitter went
from not having necessarily a product at
all to being one of the largest now
payment providers when it comes to
not only efficiency but cost and scale
and all this kind of stuff essentially
overnight right like this product didn't
exist tipping existed for a few months
now i guess uh but when it comes to kind
of the size and the scale that people
have it now they have three 350 300 350
million monthly active users i believe
right so uh from a scale perspective
it's going to be massive and i think uh
if you were to ask the executives at
venmo and all these other places like
they'd be a little nervous about it
paypal has about 350 360 uh monthly
active users twitter has almost the same
twitter literally just out of thin air
snapped their fingers integrated with
strikes api and just created the exact
same size and scale of venmo or paypal's
uh user base that doesn't mean yet that
we're there for transactions or kind of
volume standpoint but already they've
now have payment infrastructure that's
available to the same amount of users
this is a huge deal that we're watching
play out here and it goes back to how
can you be an abrasive country to a
technology that some of the largest
technology companies in your uh within
your geographic borders are embracing it
you also have banks now buying the asset
holding it you have your high net worth
individuals you also have we know
politicians holding it both congress uh
and in the senate uh both sides of the
aisle actually buying and holding the
asset you can't be abrasive to this
thing because what's gonna end up
happening is it is more likely that a
politician an elected seat gets
unelected gets kicked out and replaced
by somebody else who gets put there than
it is that this asset ends up being
banned or outlawed or anything like that
on top of that if you're an appointed
official and you start to become
abrasive to something an elected
official who appoints you will likely
end up appointing somebody else into the
position because as we go on with time
the other thing is bitcoiners started
out they were on the fringes of society
they were younger it was basically the
complete opposite of the political elite
establishment type world but now what
we're watching is that the holder base
or the investor base in bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies in general has started
to expand the demographic has uh kind of
infiltrated into higher uh older
demographics also the people who started
10 years ago are 10 years older now we
also went from the fringes of society to
now we've got banks et cetera so you get
this expanding group of people holding
bitcoin well what's gonna happen now
they're running for political seats now
they're actually rising and they're
becoming the managers the directors the
ceos the c-suite of some of these
corporations these organizations you end
up actually as time goes on getting
bitcoiners into positions of power and
influence and ultimately what will
happen is they are going to be much more
sympathetic to this than let's say the
elite establishment groups of 10 years
ago and we're already seeing that play
out now right yeah i think uh dare i say
too big to fail right right like there's
politicians that hold it like you said
people own a company's own it on their
balance sheet banks are transacting in
it etfs are apparently going to be get
approved uh soon relative so like i
think to some standpoint yeah like it's
it's here it's obviously here to stay i
think the the the greatest thing that
the politicians that are in office
currently or the government officials
could do is figure out ways to adopt it
uh and be innovative around it
john what do you think is uh kind of the
most interesting way when you talk to
your friends who are in their mid-20s
when you say something about bitcoin do
they still think about it as an
investment or are they starting to think
more about it in terms of being able to
use it for medium of exchange i think
it's definitely more of a an investment
in an asset that they hold and think
it's going to gain value over time
that's what i was going to bring up too
is that just like i think more people in
general think of it as an investment and
not as that medium exchange just based
off the fixed supply asset of it and uh
where they're located in the world
definitely matters so p more people in
el salvador probably think of it as a
medium of exchange when more people in
the u.s definitely view it as an
investment there's no there's no figures
i have on that but that's just my
general base yeah it's it's just what
you what you kind of see all right we're
going to move on to the next topic but
before we do that let's go we're at 780
likes we get to 1.5 k likes today and
we're gonna give away an eight sleep
mattress to one person in the audience
i'm gonna count to three you all are
gonna hit the like button when i hit
three one two three smash the like
button let's go we got a free entry free
content you just turn on your computer
you turn on your smart tv maybe you're
using a roku maybe you're not you just
watch the show free content you get
educated all we ask is that you hit the
like button so that more people on
youtube will see this real simple don't
say we never did anything for you guys
and you can go and get the new merch
that we're all wearing the bestbusiness
show.com miami go get it all right we've
got el salvador now back in june
nick carter who is a fan of the show who
is a partner of the show who is
basically like an extended uh honorary
pump brother at this point who will be
coming back to the show on a periodic
basis was holding a twitter spaces uh
and
i joined a couple other people joined we
started talking about what's going on in
el salvador they were putting forth the
bitcoin bill uh then all of a sudden one
of president bukelli's brothers he
jumped in then a second brother jumped
in then all of a sudden president
buchelli himself out of nowhere off the
top rope 360 dunk he jumped in jack
dorsey mark cuban it was like the whole
internet was in this twitter space
there's over 20 000 people in there and
we started to ask the president a bunch
of different questions some of the
questions were real simple why are you
doing this how does the legislation work
what's the opposition think etc but then
out of nowhere alex gladstein asked the
president have you thought about using
state resources to mine bitcoin or
participate in the mining process and
president buchelli what seemed like kind
of an offhand comment at the time said
oh actually we have a ton of energy from
volcanoes we have volcano energy and
we've actually been thinking about
potentially mining bitcoin using that
volcano energy now you can imagine being
in one of these twitter spaces late at
night on the east coast 20 000 people
all listening to hear the president of a
nation say that he's going to use
volcano energy to start mining bitcoin
people went nuts now what ended up
happening was there was a lot of
questions are they actually gonna mine
bitcoin with volcano energy or is this
just a politician making uh campaign
promises and and trying to say the
things that he thinks people are gonna
be excited about well we now have the
story el salvador has started to mine
bitcoin using energy from volcano so
they've actually built it we talked
earlier this week we got a little teaser
video they came out and they said hey
it's getting close now
we have true confirmation so el salvador
i was looking it up this morning the
best business show research team it's
known as the land of volcanoes what does
that mean i don't know but that's what
the internet says they got a lot of
volcanoes and they look pretty dope i
don't know who took this picture but
it's awesome and so when you start to
think about a volcano i think most
people like think of the concept but
they forget no they erupt there's uh
lava that comes out on these are real
things and there's just the uh
geothermal energy that's inside of them
and so in this land of the volcanoes the
president of el salvador posted about
six hours ago seven hours ago an account
balance he literally just posted this is
as transparent as you possibly can get
and what you can see here is that they
have started to mine satoshi's that's
right
the country of el salvador has bought
mining equipment for bitcoin they have
plugged it into the geothermal power
that comes from the volcano energy
within the volcanoes in their country
and they now are mining bitcoin he then
followed it up with another tweet that
said we're still testing and installing
but this is officially the first bitcoin
mining from the
the volcanoed
[Laughter]
which is a great
great marketing term here and also i
would like to say that you have to
respect uh boo kelly's use hashtags uh
emojis like the guy understands the
internet right
he tweeted literally just like the like
happy face with like hearts around it
when he showed the set the second go
back to the uh the first tweet that he
had and also i mean you gotta respect
that uh what we showed yesterday i think
the chivo wallet dashboard he's just
like hey look here's the stats also
here's the account balance like imagine
if the uh u.s president was just out
here tweeting the fed balance sheet uh
and then oh wait hold on let us edit it
real quick oh we just had another
trillion dollars all right but and when
you see this
the first thought i had this morning
was
damn the country of el salvador is
moving faster and is becoming more
effective than most technology startups
like if i as a technology investor in
early stage startups saw a founder that
was doing this i would want to invest
right because i would say wow they set a
plan they executed quickly they're
communicating in a transparent way and
they're building an entire following
around this and then they're basically
doing the building in public and then on
top of that they're getting results
to go from we didn't even think of el
salvador as a country to do with
anything let alone with bitcoin to today
look at them as a leader on a global
stage in this specific fast-growing
industry and to have them already have
bought bitcoin already have over two
million of their uh uh citizens on board
it to an app that they built using atms
that they installed in the last 90 days
and on top of that now they're mining
bitcoin this has got to be one of the
most incredible things we've seen a
nation state do in a while yeah i mean
it's all happened very very very fast it
seems right i think i'm more curious too
like at what level do you think this is
for uh
kind of good purposes or at what level
do you think he's doing this because
he's getting kind of uh the publicity
and el salvador's receiving probably
attention on a global scale that they
haven't before right i think like
obviously that first mover advantage is
helpful from an innovation standpoint
but it also comes with we've talked
about this before like kind of the
publicity or the idea that you're
innovative or the idea that you are kind
of the first country of the people to be
doing this i assume part of that is is
it plays a role in his decision to be so
public about it and facing on twitter
and telling people exactly what he's
doing of course if every time you tweet
and you say we're doing this and people
go nuts what do you do
it's just dopamine hit so you do it
again right and what do you tweet again
people go nuts you tweet again and so at
some point you actually almost have the
marketing take over because you run out
of things to brag about so you have to
get things done in order to brag about
it he wouldn't be able to still be
tweeting be like oh we passed the
legislation like people like dude we got
it like you you did that months ago
right then all of a sudden the wallet
we're gonna launch the wallet that got a
whole news cycle and then you got at
some point people were like all right
dude we know you're gonna build the wall
where is it oh we launched it open the
whole new news cycle then it's like okay
now you got the wallet well is anyone
using it news cycle is anyone using atms
news cycle hey remember that thing you
said about volcano energy what's going
on there oh we did it bam news cycle so
what they're doing is they're just
constantly executing and again you can
like them not like them whatever i'm not
a expert on salvadorian politics i don't
want to be but i think as you see that
execution you start to say hey things in
motion stay in motion and they have a
track record now of executing very
quickly very efficiently and when that
occurs in a fast-growing industry like
this i wouldn't bet against them i would
not bet against this team that is
happens to be running a country but
could might as well just be running a
technology company because this is what
you would want to see out of a tech
entrepreneur as they are executing at
this speed they have over 20 volcanoes
in el salvador land of the volcanoes
like i said
john what do you think in a world where
governments are historically
slow to adapt and innovate especially in
new technology it's very impressive what
he's done it makes me a little worrisome
that he's almost moving too quickly um
but because there are there are risks
associated with everything right with
adopting a new technology like this on
such a wide scale but it is very
impressive that he's been able to do it
in such a quick manner and uh
effectively as well we got politicians
here complaining about the uh the energy
use of bitcoin uh talking about other
countries and how they want to shut it
down and how it's dangerous and all this
stuff and this guy in the span of of two
three months went out there not only is
adapting it where a large percent 30 or
40 percent of his entire country now
owns bitcoin but also they're mining it
from volcanoes it's it's it's uh super
impressive uh he obviously has some kind
of distinct advantage when it comes to
the relative small size of his country
and his ability to make decisions
personally but ultimately uh it's just
too drastic kind of things that we've
seen not only from the united states but
you look at someone like china who's
actively going out and banning it and
stopping people from adopting this
technology and then you look at him and
he is not only encouraging people to use
it but he's putting an aggressive plan
into action
not only to give his citizens bitcoin
but to mine it himself the piece that
nobody seems to give them credit for is
that they've done this also with the
pressure of the imf and other countries
being like hey i don't know if we like
what you're doing here what's your plan
et cetera and they're not getting
support oh he was chirping at him yeah i
mean yeah they're they're not getting
support
this is absolutely a small group of
people who said we're gonna go change
the role and again maybe it has positive
impact maybe has negative impact you can
debate all of that but you cannot deny
that there's a small group of people in
this country that said we believe that
there is a better future and we're going
to go after it and whether they are
successful or not is still up for uh
kind of debate and we'll have great
hindsight bias when we look at the
results but the early signs of this are
incredible he's already got a piece of
software in the market that has more
active users than any other bank in all
of el salvador
when you think about that like it's
crazy 2 million users i think the
country only has six or seven million
citizens so he's already got about a
third of his country on board in a
matter of weeks to a new piece of
software and they in 70 of his country
doesn't even have a bank account and so
when you start to see where this is
going i can't believe that there's not
gonna be another country that says wow
it seems like bitcoin's good for
business you know what we should do uh
we should create legislation to make it
legal tender you know what else we
should do we create a piece of software
on board our country maybe we should
also create an atm network
you know we've probably got some energy
sources around here too maybe we should
go by mine bitcoin as well
and if they see the playbook work it's
almost like a bitcoin nation state
playbook is being created right in front
of our eyes similar to how michael
saylor at microstrategy created a
corporate balance sheet bitcoin playbook
and then he open sourced and said hey
anyone who wants to do this go do it
then we saw square we saw
tesla spacex et cetera all start to do
this we saw the bitcoin miners that are
publicly traded doing it as well i can't
imagine that other nation states aren't
sitting there saying like yep that is
the way let's go do it like yeah and if
you look at the adoption curve it starts
to accelerate right when you have not
only sure michael saylor was looked like
he was looked like an idiot or wild when
he first started doing this now there's
a bunch of uh kind of influential ceos
and companies that are putting on their
balance sheet and owning bitcoin
personally el salvador might be the
first country but you can quickly see
how other countries look at the playbook
like you said and then go out and adopt
it very quickly so anytime you have uh
kind of someone they get rewarded for
being that first mover but then it
starts to accelerate very quickly right
so el salvador may be the first i think
there's going to be a bunch of other
countries that probably end up doing it
eventually the real question just
becomes like how soon does it how soon
does it happen right is it three months
six months 12 months and then when you
look at it overlaid with the price if
the price starts to appreciate really
rapidly you can quickly see how these
people are forced to make decisions much
quicker than they would be so i wouldn't
be surprised if you look uh you know
this time next year and other countries
have adopted it or other countries are
actively looking to not only mine
bitcoin but give it to their citizens or
own a large percentage on their balance
sheets personally you would have to
believe that other countries are
analyzing and reviewing what is
happening in el salvador and then going
to take that and make their own
decisions based off that
the part that uh also feels um important
here is the everyday citizens
are not just going to transact with each
other so if you're if you're a
salvadorian who lives in el salvador
you're definitely going to go to
merchants you're going to send money
back and forth to other citizens live in
the country you also are sending money
back and forth with folks who live
outside of the country sometimes it's
your family your friends et cetera
reminds us is a very big part of the
salvadorian gdp
but those individuals start to onboard
then they get money in their accounts
and then they start to do it money is
the most viral product in the world and
so when you start to spin that viral
machine what happens is it just
infiltrates remember what i used to say
the virus is spreading you somehow in
2020 and 2021 weren't allowed to say it
i'm bringing it back the virus is
spreading it literally spreads like this
one mind virus this idea that once i
learned about bitcoin i can't stop
thinking about i tell joe about it joe's
like wow i got orange build as well now
he can't stop thinking about he tells
john and it just spreads across a entire
population but also the virality of the
money itself if i want to go ahead and
send money to joe i say to him hey man
you got to be able to use an interface
that's plugged into the lightning
network whether you're using the chivo
wallet or you're using something else
and it constantly just pulls and pulls
and pulls more and more users onto the
network when you do that that is where
you end up getting the true viral
exponential kind of escape velocity
growth that we're seeing in the bitcoin
network
you agree
i do agree i'm excited to see q4 what do
we call it's october
hold it up we'll do that
hold it up q4 you guys you guys know do
you guys know what this is right do it
again do it again when you hold up for
when you're playing football fourth
quarter fourth quarter in the fourth
quarter fourth quarter that's right we
we play in the fourth quarter they had
us last quarter they had they had us the
whole game but it's the fourth quarter
baby it's the fourth quarter are we
gonna finish it how are we gonna close
it out fourth quarter that's what we
should just start every show just just
hold it up if you're at home
if you're at home here's how we're gonna
pick it i know we're gonna hit 1.5 k
likes is what we're gonna do today you
know how we're gonna pick who gets it i
want you if you're sitting at home right
now i need you to hold up four fingers
and take a selfie and post it on twitter
and just tag us fourth quarter you can
literally just say bitcoin 4q like this
this is how we're gonna pick today's
winner for the uh
for the eight sleep hashtag bitcoin4q i
need you sitting at home holding up four
fingers like this with a selfie whoever
does that and tweets it use hashtag
bitcoin4q will pick a winner we'll do it
before the end of the show so hurry up
let's get going and we're gonna pick who
wins the eight sleep today so make sure
that you end up going ahead liking the
video hit us with a fourth quarter uh uh
tweet and photo and then we'll get
rocking and rolling we've got a uh
break breaking news maybe this is a
little breaking news action oh well
michael saylor just tweeted this uh
more bitcoin pretty good no
uh bitcoins
is it bitfarms deposited 96
of their bitcoin production into custody
this year rather than sell it on the
open market if other publicly traded
miners do the same bitcoin stock to flow
is going to infinity then it is going
negative this is not factored into
anyone's model michael saylor coming out
king [ __ ] right here that's what's going
on when you say that the stock the flow
is going to infinity and then it is
going negative this is not factored into
anyone's model you better have a pretty
good reason for saying that and his
point is that bit farms a publicly
traded entity deposited 96
of what they mined into custody rather
than selling it for dollars so when
these institutions these organizations
or individuals continue to stack sats
whether you're a big publicly traded
mining firm or you're an individual
sitting at home literally buying a
dollar a day when you continue to stack
sats it continues to pull supply out of
the market and it increases that
illiquid supply will's coming on uh in a
few minutes and we're going to talk
explicitly about this idea but we're
seeing now publicly traded businesses 96
of what they produced or their revenue
in bitcoin ends up getting put into
storage not being sold on the market you
just don't have nearly as much cell
pressure and so ultimately if people do
that for decades and decades and decades
it ends up creating one of the most
interesting market structures in the
entire financial markets in my opinion
yeah i think also if you look at the
chart uh it looks like they're mining a
decent amount more than they were in the
previous months you know some of that
obviously has to do with price and all
that kind of stuff also uh but if you
have someone who's mining three 400
bitcoin a month that is saying hey we're
going to place 95 96 of this in custody
rather than go sell it out to dollars
you can quickly see how that how that
shifts uh the supply demand equation
even even more aggressively kind of in
in the favor of people that are bullish
on bitcoin fix supply
when you when you look at uh the entire
um bitcoin supply here we know that
people aren't selling and that sets up
for this idea of shocktober uh the
bigger story though is
on chain metrics is one thing will's
about to talk about that in a second
retail investors is another we have
publicly traded companies doing this and
then they explicitly are talking about
it this is a publicly traded ceo michael
saylor microstrategy talking about
another publicly traded company strategy
doing this and so when you now get this
entering into the conversation it gets
normalized in public markets every
single corporation's gonna start saying
hey should we be stacking sats
should we be stacking sats
what are we gonna miss this are we gonna
not participate here are we going to
hold dollars or any other fiat currency
that's being devalued at a historic rate
or are we going to get in the game
and at some point somebody in the
organization says hey let's not be
stupid here right the opportunity cost
is higher to not participate than to
participate let's get in the game let's
start stacking satsang let's keep it off
the uh off the market in illiquid form
the answer is yes to your question about
if they should start stacking hats of
course
of course all right i think we've got
will here we're not even going to go to
commercial we're just going straight
through power and right through what we
need
what we need you all to do is smash the
like button let's go if we get to 1.5 k
we're gonna go ahead we're gonna give
away one eight sleep mattress the fourth
quarter pictures are rolling in
fourth quarter baby they had us the
whole game but it's all about the fourth
quarter that's what it is john loves the
fourth grade about that fourth quarter
fourth quarter
fourth quarter
by the way you know you know who
reminded me of this and told me that we
should do it yeah john street capital my
guy he's suited anonymous maybe we're
gonna get him on a show uh sometime next
week but he told me he said yo bitcoins
popping i'm expecting the pomp boys to
be strutting into the show today holding
four fingers up like we're going to the
fourth quarter of the football game so
shout out to him uh all right let's pull
up will and uh let's see what's going on
with the on-chain metrics for uh for
this week well what's up well
hey what's going on guys
let's go we got audio
come on my guy is ready he said fourth
quarter will give us a little four
fingers in the air for the fourth
quarter
[Laughter]
let's go will's been saying the entire
like all summer long he said listen
shocktober supply squeeze ready to rock
and roll all right buddy you ready to go
always all right let's start first with
uh what what's going on uh in terms of
sopra sopra me and will hung out all
summer we had a sopra summer what uh
what's going on there
yeah so soper looks at the profit-taking
uh or i'm sorry the the state of profit
that the market is holding on any given
day so you're taking a ratio of all the
coins trading in profit all the coins
trading in loss and you get super and
then here we look at a soaper which is
adjusting for all the outputs below an
hour
and then we're also
doing a seven day moving average on this
so we're looking at essentially the
weekly version of soper
and so as you can see recently that
we've just bounced off one you know
obviously that's a good sign so far but
we want to see
obviously an uptrend in the in the ratio
but at least you know at the minimum um
some stabilization above one um you know
in bearish markets you fade the the
retests of one and then in a in a
bullish trend uh you know in a broader
bullish trend
you buy the dips along one um and so if
we are in a broader bullish trend which
i personally believe we are but
it's up to you for to to decide
um all these retests of one will become
you know good off buy opportunities um
if if you're correct about that
assumption so
we just bounced off of it you know once
again want to see some stabilization but
preferably you know increase in the
ratio
i definitely think we're in a bull
market i think you do as well so it's
great to see it bouncing off of off that
one tell us what's going on with the
whales we've got this chart that filters
out all of the kind of exchanges and
known entities uh but explain to us
what's going on here with this whale
chart
yeah so this is just looking at all the
entity flows um so the green line we
have whales this is filter out for
exchanges grayscale qbtc
the purpose etf then we have a couple
different lines here we have the shrimps
the crabs the fish octopus so it's just
saying all these different size cohorts
and so what you see is
the high level you know take away is
that every
single cohort is accumulating right now
as of the last three weeks when you
started to see
the 100 to 1000 btc guys start to buy as
well so right now you have every single
cohort uh accumulating which is which is
pretty remarkable you know when you go
back and
look at times where you see all cohorts
accumulating in unison uh that's that's
historically you know been a pretty good
time to average and supplies i don't
have a chart of that up here but i have
put that on my twitter in the past it's
happened a couple times before and so
you ask you know where are these coins
coming from
and the answer is exchanges right we
keep talking about how coins are moving
off exchanges
in the last week you have
2869 btc moved off exchanges
which is about
134 million dollars i think i used a 47k
btc price for that
and they're also down 62
251 btc in the last month which is about
3.2 billion dollars
and so this this leads us to the next
chart um you know you see that that uh
purple line is the exchange supply shock
ratio so comparing all the coins on
exchanges to off blue line we talked
about this a lot the liquid supply ratio
you're comparing um the strong hands to
the weak hands essentially so the
entities that statistically sell a lot
the entities that's this
bit rarely sell right
and so we have another bullish
divergence when you you know look at
both ratios in comparison to price price
is kind of bleeding sideways bearish
well i put this out i created this last
night so as of this morning maybe that's
starting to change
and then you know this is the same thing
that happened in in the summer we were
tracking so um that those are the supply
dynamics the one thing i wanted to i
wanted to touch on was just the um the
bids i think this is like important for
people to to keep in mind um it's the
second chart
so what you're looking at here is all
the it's just a heat map of all the biff
and x orders uh the all the the bids and
asks on the order book
and so what you see is we have this huge
floor below us
and so
you you can look at this two ways um the
bullish case is obviously like okay the
the chinese bull whales have just set
this concrete floor um and you know you
have started to see started to see some
of those orders filling the other day
but the the perhaps more nuanced view
and i'm not saying this this is the case
i'm just saying keep this in mind um the
bearish case would be that these walls
sometimes are used to generate liquidity
to uh either enter or exit positions so
you could you could set a huge wall of
bids right and then whenever the you
know the retail guys start to see price
you know bleeding down into that wall or
or floor i should say
they're going to try to front run that
because they see hope there's this huge
wall like no one's going to sell into
that so i'm going to start selling or
closing my shorts above that on the
other end
or i'm sorry closing my lungs above that
on the other end you could have that
entity that set the set the floor
actually using that liquidity to exit
the market and then conversely if they
set a giant wall of asks you know it
could be them actually trying to enter
into the market they're basically
putting a cap on the price everyone is
is trying to front run that wall and
sells into that or closes you know
closes their lungs or open shorts uh
like front running that wall and on the
other end of that are actually uh the
same entities that or entity that
created that wall uh or ceiling um are
actually in in the market you know
getting long so
you you
you know there's there's nuance to it um
but as i mentioned like the other day
you have started to see some of these
these bids fill um going back though
like
biffin x
activity i could say um has has been
pretty influential on the price like you
see them cap price a lot and set the
floor often times
it's just you know keep an eye on it
because if you just see the floor get
rugged then you know that's not a good
sign
one of the things that i i really like
that you're doing right now is not only
are you looking at metrics that uh david
puel willie wu and many other folks uh
kind of before you uh have created and
spent a bunch of time uh on but you're
also creating a bunch of new metrics as
well and one of them that you included
in the newsletter uh this week was this
idea of a delta valuation model and
trying to determine like this floor idea
explain exactly what you're trying to
get at with the metric and then show us
what it's uh uh kind of highlighting
today
sure so
last week we looked at the liquid supply
floor
and so that was looking at basically an
estimate of the real-time floor that
long-term investors or strong hands have
set
this is uh a bit more conservative in
the in the sense that the floor has
never been broken whereas the model last
week it's been broken briefly twice
this is looking at um
where should i start so delta cap is the
difference between and this was
conceptualized by david poi delta cap is
the difference between the average cap
so the all-time moving average cap
in realized cap and realize cap is
basically an on-chain view op so it's
it's looking at the last time coins were
last move and creating a capitalization
based off of that so for example um you
know let's say i'm roger vayer i bought
bitcoin at a dollar about a hundred
thousand btc at a dollar right and i've
never moved them you know in market cap
that that chunk of coins right is worth
four
4.7 billion dollars i hope i just did
that public math correctly and then
if he has it if he hasn't moved those
coins it's only adding a hundred
thousand dollars uh to realize cap and
so you're it's it's basically giving you
this average uh pr or price or
capitalization you know you just divide
the cap by the circulating supply to get
the to get realized price but you're
looking at this average capitalization
based off of where these investors have
bought into the market
and so taking the difference of that is
what delta cap is and that's given you
as you'll see by these little green
circles um it's giving you these these
good buy zones especially just saying
you know okay we're getting close to the
to delta cap that's probably a good time
to average in some heavier buys or you
can statistically take riskier buys
right because the asymmetry of of the
market at that time is heavily skewed to
the upside because we're very close to
what's historically been the floor um
and so then you take a multiple of that
and you get the delta cap top and so
that's that purple line it's just
multiplying it by a special number uh
seven and a half which is completely
arbitrary i just played around with it
until it fit
[Music]
and so you see that that that's caught
some of the tops as well and then you
just take both of those divide by two
which just taking the mean of it and you
get that little middle uh the middle uh
blue line and that's there's been you
know historically a
you know level that price has interacted
pretty pretty nicely with like you look
at 2019 that's where it bounced off of
in that little mini uh bull run
um so yeah that that's the model it's
just not nothing crazy um it's just you
know you can use that in confluence with
the liquid supply floor and you know
this is like a much more conservative uh
floor that because it you know once
again it's never been broken
you know we also have shown before i
think the pricing models using like
willy's top model which is at like 190k
that's using an all-time moving average
of bitcoin
i've also seen pricing similar pricing
models using thermo cap which is
the security spend of miners so there's
different ways right you can you can
kind of create these valuation models
but it's interesting like you know
this is all based off of the the on the
unchain activity and
you know we can kind of create these
valuation methods for bitcoin where we
don't have like discount cash flows or
anything like that
when we look at the bitcoin number of
active entities uh it feels like this
has been really lockstep with uh bitcoin
price uh but we're starting to see kind
of an increase uh over the last couple
of uh days and weeks
right yeah like i think the the one
bearish case you could make from an
on-chain perspective is just looking at
some of the transactional
activity excuse me um so you look at
transaction count
you know the mempool overall volume
active entities also net entities growth
which is the difference between
the new entities coming on chain and the
ones leaving
and basically you know some of these
things are showing that there's low
demand to use the network um although we
have seen as you mentioned uh you know
uptick recently but you know from a
broader standpoint we still are
historically you know lower than where
we have have been in you know bull
market uptrends but i think you can make
an argument a counter argument to this
and say three things um first of all
that the speculative market participants
are gone so we're seeing like
transaction volume is dominated by these
larger guys so we're looking at like
volume of 10 million dollars and up has
seen a very large increase over the last
few weeks and it's just completely
dominating all the volume on every given
day
also another another culprit could be
batching done by exchanges so i know a
couple guys who work with exchanges and
um
i guess now over you know over the last
couple months they've started to utilize
batching more to save the money and and
i guess it just saves them hassle as
well
and then lastly uh and this is probably
the more popular answer with bitcoiners
but i think it's honestly the the
least effective of the three um on the
lack of transactional activity and
that's transactions migrating to the
lightning network
so go ahead well i was going to ask so
when you think about that lightning
network uh you've got a bunch of charts
here what's your before we get into the
graphics what's your general thought
process around the lightning network at
the moment is this something that people
should really be paying attention to or
is it still too early to get overly
excited about it
i think i think it's huge right like
you're seeing what jack's doing you had
jack on last week and you know
this is completely changing uh you know
how we do things like you know you look
at countries where they don't have
access to banking
you know you look at remittances and how
that's changed things for countries you
know like el salvador for example um you
know i think i think the lightning
network is just crucial in general for
transitioning bitcoin from a you know
predominantly a store of value we talk
about bitcoin is is the most efficient
way to move value across uh space and
time right that's from safety dean's uh
the bitcoin standard but the lightning
network helps us transition to more of
that medium uh medium of exchange right
we talk about
you know you go from like collectibles
to store value medium of exchange to
unit of account and so the lightning
network will although still young you
know eventually help us make that
transition and i think at some point you
won't even know you're interacting with
the lightning network um and you know
it's it's it you know from being being
just a bitcoiner you know it's really
cool to see like which what jack did
with twitter and what's going on in el
salvador and seeing you know lightning
network and like starbucks and
mcdonald's uh i think it's still early
days but you're seeing you know i think
you're just starting to kind of hit that
s curve in terms of lightning adoption
when we look at these charts on
lightning itself one piece uh that seems
to just kind of jump out to me is the
channel size uh the number of channels
even the number of nodes these are only
the public numbers right this is only
the channels and nodes that we know of
is there an idea as to what the
non-public size is is it 30 bigger 50
percent what's kind of your take on that
i think that's a great question i just
don't know um i don't know either maybe
yeah maybe there's been like a a study
or someone's put out like a little
research paper on it but yeah i i
haven't i haven't heard anything about
you know how we how you would even go
about estimating that um maybe maybe
some of the guys that like lightning
labs would know
yeah i i don't know what the answer is
the number that i've heard and again
this is like literally i heard from
somebody who heard from somebody was
somewhere between 25 to 30
of the network is not in public channels
or publicly uh
uh addressable nodes but you know who
knows what that number could be my guess
is it's not one percent and it's not
double right it's probably somewhere in
between there even if we are we're you
know we're looking at you know like five
six thousand btc of capacity so you know
it's it's it's still very very tiny
agreed let's talk about miners uh we
were just talking about uh michael
saylor had these a couple of comments
about uh miners putting much more of uh
what they're producing into storage
rather than selling it on the open
market is the on-chain metric showing uh
pretty much the same thing
i'm sorry i missed like the first part i
put out a bit but talk to us about the
miners in terms of hash rate difficulty
and what they're doing with the bitcoin
that they're introducing
got it yeah sure so
let's go in the last chart um this is
you'll see in orange is is the hash and
then blue is difficulty
and so
the difficulty adjustment was one of
satoshi's you know uh most innovative
creations in my opinion because it's
essentially you know pegging issuance to
uh
the energy securing the network and so
whenever whenever you have hash come on
the network you have a positive
difficulty adjustment whenever you see
hash moving off the network you have a
negative difficulty adjustment and so
the last time we had five um you know
consecutive positive difficulty
adjustments um was early 2020 in like
january february time frame we had four
earlier this year but yeah the last time
we had five was early 2020 so
this is just another way to look at as
you can see in the with the orange line
uh hash is coming back on the network uh
we had that you know huge chinese minor
migration you're now starting to see
that hash get plugged in elsewhere
around the world um and so yeah i'm
bullish hash
it it feels like we are uh back in
business hashrate is coming back
aggressively uh joe and john what
questions do you guys have in terms of
what's going on right now bill uh well i
mean uh bill
i was reading something about it again
damn joe
hey will hey will man i got you he's
fired no problem fire joe hey bill
well uh my question uh is about kind of
what you look at outside of on chain
metrics so um we've seen a lot of price
action especially in the equity markets
and and debt markets as well do you
spend any time looking at that relative
to the on-chain metrics or do you only
uh focus on kind of what's happening in
bitcoin and think there's no kind of
correlation
no they're definitely correlated um
it's just funny though like sometimes we
go through these spurious like really
heavily correlation heavy correlations
and then obviously if you're like a
liquidity crunch like all correlations
you know are gonna you know come
together but
um
i i have been watching you know
obviously the sby and the dxy lately
over the last couple months or so um you
have seen some strong correlation there
partially because you've had a lot of
this you know macro uncertainty so
you've just seen in general um you know
like some risk off behavior we saw that
with the whole evergreen thing
aside from aside from that you know i
keep an eye on those things you know
like i wake up in the morning check the
dixie see the s p or the s p futures um
you know check tenure
um
and then
you know in terms of in terms of like
technical indicators i look at you know
just basic oscillators like rsi
um
you know i just look for basic
divergences and stuff i look at price
structure just you know very very
general levels i don't draw like 20
million lines on the screen but you know
i just draw some important levels that i
think
um you know bitcoins interacted with
over the last couple months um and then
i like i mentioned earlier i look at the
you know the order books so i use
trading light which is a great platform
it's just a heat map of all the bids and
asks and then lastly and this is
probably the most the thing i check most
often
is the derivatives data so i look at you
know the funding rate off across all
different exchanges
and then also the the futures basis and
then open interest as well uh because
you know derivatives data affects uh the
price in the short term is along with
price structure whereas on chain is more
tracking the broader trends so if you
want to you know look at perhaps what's
going to happen over the next couple
days next few hours you know look at
that derivatives data and also you know
shorter term price structure you can you
know oscillators too you know like if
rsi is is way overbought or oversold
basic things like that
john what questions you got big dog
what's up will nice mic nice headphones
great good setup you got there
um so i'm curious going into q4 what are
the big movers going to be here is it
all going to be just based off the
supply on the exchanges like how do you
think about it and then
when and if this bitco this bull run
ends when when do you see that happening
yeah i think like you know we've been
we've been tracking a lot of these
supply dynamics for a while and we'll
start to see them come into fruition
where you know over the next couple
months we've been talking about since
summer that we'll probably see them come
into fruition later this year into maybe
january of next year
um as far as like the the ending of the
bull market i mean i have no idea you
know like going off of historical
four-year cycles then perhaps you're
looking at december january
um also you know you have like tax you
know people selling bitcoin for tax
purposes at the end of the year
um but it's it's hard to say like you
know i'm just gonna follow the data and
whenever the the data starts flipping
bearish like i'll flip bearish if you
start to see you know a bunch of coins
um you know moving on to exchanges see
coins becoming liquid you sort of see
old guy you know older coins really just
uh dumping so you see whales dumping um
you know those kinds of things
but
for now you know i'm just following
following the trend man that's it's i i
don't really know i i would say end of
year to to the beginning of next year
just based off like these historical
four-year cycles but
as we every as we mentioned earlier you
know
i i'm starting to kind of move away from
the camp that we operate in these
four-year cycles i think
over time um this is like a whole nother
discussion we can have but i think
bitcoin starts to become more
free-floating um you know not saying
that we don't have any drawdowns but i
think
you know we move away from that very
pretty you know cup structure every four
years and you look at bitcoin on like a
logarithmic chart yeah it's a good point
about the uh taxes as well at the end of
the year
will
what's going on with college life you
still on campus just uh not going to
class
yeah i'm just vibing man
we're gonna send you one of these shirts
you can't vibe unless you got a best
business show miami edition shirt you're
gonna need one of those i know that
north carolina gets a little cold but
it's always summer in miami so when
you're wearing it it's just you just
bring your mind to somewhere nice and
warm on the beach
yeah you send it to me i'll wear it on
the show for sure
i need you wearing that at uh the
darties there on saturdays
[Music]
john what you know about dardy's i know
a little bit he's been doing it yeah
you've been doing i went to college no i
haven't been to ecu maybe i'll come
visit you well we'll do it me and you
and then we'll we'll zoom in with them
we'll have bill and john live reporting
from
[Laughter]
you know you know that meme and it's
like the guy in the club like whispering
with bring to the girl and she looks
like really annoying
we need to make one and it's like super
bounced off one
[Laughter]
will what are your friends are they are
they getting on board now are they more
excited that uh that you dropped out and
uh bitcoin they're getting excited about
it or they still think you're crazy
no i mean they don't think i'm crazy
like
i think a lot of them a lot of them just
buy bitcoin because they're like oh he
must know what he's talking about kind
of thing but a lot of my buddies are
interested in it you know it's just they
want to know what i even do
um you know i i teach them i teach them
a little bit about like the on-chain
stuff but for the most part you know
they just
you know they buy a little bit hold it
you know and i i got the marge filled a
bit
i love it i love it um all right i just
put into the chat uh will's twitter
account so make sure that you guys all
go follow them i mean you've just been
dropping bombs on people non-stop it
seems like uh so keep up the great work
um anything that you want to leave leave
the people with in terms of uh what
you're thinking about kind of moving
forward
i mean i don't know i just think it's
going to be exciting next couple months
um you know keep your eyes peeled i
think we've we've seen some you know
strong accumulation
um
over the you know the last couple months
especially since like you know july 20th
27th 28th so like very end of july um
perhaps maybe we'll start to see some of
those buyers stick their neck out and
say who they are
i remember you know we had we had sailor
announced and that was all on the
on-chain data guys i forget the numbers
but you know i remember i put out a
tweet two weeks ago maybe it was just
saying you know we've been tracking
whales have bought x amount of coins
right like that was in the data that
sailor bought and whatever he bought i
forget exactly how much but you know
there's he he bought a fraction in terms
of what we've seen whales buying and um
you know who those people are maybe
maybe we'll find out over the next
couple months
um so there's a little hopium opium for
the audience but uh yeah guys i hope you
have a great weekend and thanks for
having me on as always whenever you want
to come to ecu i got you
listen we need you to put up the four
fingers they had us in the first half
will they had us in the first half but
fourth quarter is bitcoin's quarter
that's that's the message today john you
want to go to ecu
yeah we'll figure out a weekend
well you're gonna do like some keg
stands or something nah i know keg said
it's gonna be happening why not not why
not you don't like that you only have a
good time i like having a good time all
right well so what keg stands you're
gonna be violent i'll personally deliver
the shirt will
you should link up with mr beast listen
will and john vibing
at a party on the weekend at ecu is the
last thing i think that i would uh sleep
well at night knowing that john sounds
like an amazing story yeah
yo let me tell you what will and i did
this weekend we sat in front of the
computer and looked at the ancient
metrics this shit's going to go another
gazillion dollars
[Laughter]
all right well listen thank you for uh
for coming on people want you guys at
john if you go they want you to film the
whole thing and vlog it you can become
uh become the the uh the new vlogger
you in
oh we'll see about the i don't like
having evidence of weekends like that
[Laughter]
all right well thanks so much thanks
headphones mike everything looks great
we're back in action and uh we will see
you next week everyone make sure you go
follow will subscribe to the newsletter
uh that is in the bio and uh and we'll
get after it man thanks so much
thank you guys take it easy later buddy
wizard
the wizard speaks sopra sopra
the wizard speaks bounce right off one
hard like
it sopra don't stand nothing against
women i can see him at darty's like
telling girls like you know what sopra
is let me tell you
can you explain to everyone what a dardy
is before they're all like what is he
talking about day party
easiest way to put it day party how many
of those you've been to i've been to a
few what's the best dirty story you got
i don't have any dirty stories like i
said i don't like having evidence of
things that happen at parties
i would it wouldn't be your first keg
stand
it would not be my first text
i i don't know how to have fun yeah that
is true that is true when i was in
college uh i think that i remember when
i came to uh to visit joe
yes i remember yeah i can't i came to oh
and then super bounced off one there you
go
perfect
i went to go visit joe i don't think
john was in uh college yet
what were you yep oh yeah you were there
yeah yeah yeah
john and i were definitely both there uh
i went to go visit joe in college and uh
i didn't really have anybody any friends
there other than joe and john and so
they just have any friends yeah they
just kidding
no they had a party they had a party at
one of their houses or a friend's house
or whatever and so i was just standing
there i was just whatever their friends
were like oh that's like joe's brother
or whatever who's the old guy so far
yeah so they were like yeah like who's
that guy he looks a little bit older
than us so they started coming over
they're like you want a beer i was like
of course they started handing me beers
started drinking drinking drinking next
thing i know one of them handed me a uh
uh what they called a beer funnel yeah
right a funnel and so uh i mean i wasn't
gonna funnel all the beers myself so
then i literally just stood there and i
happened to be standing right in the
area where i went from the living room
to the kitchen and so the uh every time
please let me tell the story and so
every person that went by i was like hey
every single person at this party that
walked from one room to the other room
and it wasn't like a like a room that no
one went into it was the it was where
everyone's here was it was it was where
literally everyone was keeping their
beer he stood there with a funnel and
every time someone passed he would tell
them to funnel a beer and everyone was
like dude like i just grabbed this beer
first off like you know i'm trying to
just hang out and drink it and enjoy the
party
like eight out of ten people we're just
like all right fine whatever give me the
funnel and they would just and they
would hit it and at one point john walks
over and he goes to hit it and he goes
[Laughter]
and john walks over at some point he's
like yo are you making everyone funnel
beers and i'm like yeah he's like i and
he just walked right by just like
at one point because he grabbed
someone's beard and poured it in the
funnel and the kid was like i guess i'm
hitting the phone
man someone said in the chat that was
the og entry fee yeah yeah
you only got to like the video now yeah
we're letting you guys all be easy
you just have to fully you know you used
to have to funnel yeah all right we hit
1.5 k likes well of course we hit 1.5 k
all right here's what we're gonna do we
got two things that we're going to do
first already some of the photos are
coming in of four fingers up in the air
there we there's one there we go
with the day one merch i mean that's a
pretty good entry what else do we got in
there i think we got a couple of other
ones that's a pretty oh
that's a great one let's go man
you know what we should do you know do
we have any more photos or those oh
there we go there's another one oh with
us in the back guys got us on the big
screen too
there we go there we go uh there's
another one mac what up there he is look
at him in the car we got we got people
in the car we got them outside we got
them in another car we got them inside
we got them everywhere everywhere in the
world people watch the best business
show you know why because it's the best
why is it the best because we said it
was so deal with it you know what we
should do with all of these
i don't want to prom make promises for
people who have to do the work uh
because i can't do the work
but we should take all the photos
and we should make it into like a
highlight reel
and then we should overlay it with
either some music or maybe we get a
little bit of like a speech a little
high school football speech like they
had us in the first half but in the
fourth quarter that's our time yeah like
i don't know we'll see what we can draw
but in order for
you to be included in one potentially
winning an eight sleep right now and
also two if you want to be included in
the video that i just uh decided we're
gonna make which i don't know if we can
but we're gonna do it you have to tweet
using
bitcoin q4 i just put it in the uh
i just put it in the chat use hashtag
bitcoin q4 and i need a photo with you
holding four fingers up that's what
we're gonna do four fingers up joe and
john let's go fourth quarter is our
quarter bitcoins popping shocktober
supply squeeze whatever you want to call
it however you want to describe it we
all see what's happening what i was
doing one two oh no you would like to
count backwards on things four three two
one four
i only go backwards on the day crazy
well we know we didn't pass math what
i'm talking about i just did super math
what i went backwards and then ended on
the number
joe is little one two three one four joe
joe got a puppy and now he's literally
just doing like rangers
uh next week ranger might be on the show
oh is he allowed out now you're gonna
learn about out of uh just so the
audience is clear on what's going on
here because i get made fun of this
often when a puppy when you get a puppy
it is standard procedure i learned now
that i have a don't be total standard
this is standard
that a dog has to get their vaccine
shots so we took ranger to the vet he
got his first one he has to wait another
week he got he's going to get a second
one next week and then he can go out all
over miami
[Laughter]
i just want everyone to know that this
is what happened ready joe said hey the
dog can't leave the apartment and i said
okay can i go outside he goes it can go
outside on the balcony and i said all
right why is it go out there goes
because that's where it goes to the
bathroom i said find no problem so you
can go outside on the balcony but it has
to stay inside the apartment then all of
a sudden i'm not going to say who i saw
a photo with but next thing i know i see
the dog went on a trip the dog literally
went on a trip and i see a photo of
somebody carrying the did you see the
dog on the ground did you see the dog
outside walking around what is the
difference between the dog breathing in
the air or licking somebody's hand or
probably trying to jump on you or
something well it doesn't touch the
ground when it comes to a virus but okay
no problem oh the virus is only on the
ground this isn't covid that the dog's
talking about right this is standard
it's been going on forever you have to
go get the dog vaccines it's not just
for covet so what is the difference
between the dog being in your arms
versus how about the ground how about
this is that like it's handy dirty just
wash it just tell the dog when it walks
into the house
how about this you don't tell me what to
do with my dog that's that's fine but
you can't tell us that it's not allowed
outside and then take it outside and
then be like oh no it doesn't matter i
said it can't be walking around it can't
be doing all these things it might be on
the show next week tune in
i think that it's going to people need
you to clarify though it was q4 someone
in the chat ryan houston this is true i
just got a dog ryan thank you you are
obviously a responsible dog owner
bro
bro what oh
either hashtag is unacceptable
john here he goes again where he says
the the one word to pause to think of a
comeback dude let's give me a second i
need to think of something ryan how do
you know ryan used to tell the truth i
believe ryan i like this i like to see
the good in people that's the difference
between me and you you know people are
lying no
the difference is true in you
you pick somebody for uh to win
something and then you called me and
you're like yo bro i got a problem and i
said what's the problem you said 15
people have messaged me because i'm a
good guy i don't like to i don't like to
get scammed all right i i told someone
that they won and that they were getting
cash they were getting a thousand
dollars a lot of money and they seem
pumped about it 15 people hit me up
losers telling me that they're the same
person don't try to scam me that's just
wrong we're out here giving out money
don't do the wrong thing i was trying to
be nice about it i actually think i did
do the right thing which was get picture
id and and prove that that was the right
person do you think ranger watches the
show at home yeah he definitely does
he's like hey ranger ranger he's ranger
he likes smart people talking about
ranger me and john are coming over later
we're gonna break you out of that prison
don't worry we got you no ranger ranger
this is this is uh this is full
disclosure to the audience
ranger obviously cannot talk
but based on my clarify based on my
understanding of of his feelings and how
he interacts ranger clearly likes john
more than you nice
what is that based on because you come
over and you rile them up you start
messing with them you're throwing them
around you're going with john comes over
and he hangs out with him he pets them
he chills with him so john puts him down
puts him to sleep and i have fun with
him now there's a difference what's the
difference we're not going to get it
when i walk in ranger runs over wagging
his tail knows what's up when you walk
in he runs in the other room
first of all that's not true second of
all every dog does that
no yeah no literally the dogs do it
because they want to see who showed up
in the house no i didn't do it when you
showed up yeah all right i'll take a
video when i come kidnap the dog and
then you wake up from your nap you're
not coming in my apartment and you're
like where's my dog
first off
ranger and i'll send you a little
postcard all right i think it's about
time this show wraps up for the day okay
wrap it up let's go wrap it up all right
let's see what let's run through your
checklist real quick all right
sofi.com best investing platform there
is in the entire world go check it out
uh thebestbusinessshow.com slash what is
it miami miami bestbusinessshow.com
miami we got this new collection of
these t-shirts here
the best business show miami style
summer fridays uh john what else do you
have to say
you forgot the most important part we're
supposed to give away the mattress yeah
yeah we're gonna pick someone oh are we
picking them right now we're gonna go
right instead live all right all right
so who are you picking
no who are you picking oh i'm picking
yeah you're closing the show let's go oh
okay um
look at his chin like he's
abraham lincoln over here or something
let's go where was the guy like smoking
a cigarette or whatever who was that guy
i liked him i think he should get the
mattress in the car the psych ward i got
to go find him right here
yeah the psych ward let's yeah it's a
sight lord you're the winner of the
mattress bam let's go do we do we have
uh oh how do we know who uh we gotta dm
him on twitter i'll dm him right now all
right johnson with the follow too
he follows you no it doesn't he doesn't
even follow me and you got picked
you probably find ridiculous you should
follow me after this though
all right that's the winner of uh of the
eight mattress the psycho award i can't
believe that's who we picked but let's
rock and roll i'd like to see whoa whoa
whoa when i close the show i pick a
person when you close the show you can
pick your own person don't be
criticizing my pick over all right all
right will you please just close the
show so i can go show's done the show's
over see y'all on monday
pay off your credit cards credit cards
last pump have a great great weekend we
hope you have a fantastic weekend
[Music]
you